an annual event in tan prover supporters
gather outside what used to be the US
Embassy to Mark the day University
students stormed these walls and held 52
Americans hostage for 444 days since
then there have been no diplomatic
relations between tan and
Washington now with us backing Israel's
war on Gaza and Iran's continued support
of Palestinian resistance groups and the
so-called AIS of resistance the two
adversaries have never been closer to
conflict this cruelty that's imposed on
the Palestinians is felt by people
around the world this is a move to show
solidarity with
Palestinians 44 years ago these students
were demanding the Sha of Iran stand
trial for what they called crimes
against his own people Muhammad rash sha
was receiving cancer treatment in the US
he had left Iran in January 1979 weeks
before the return of imami who overthrew
the monarchy and declared the country an
Islamic Republic this year's
commemoration is more charged than ever
before as Israel's war on Gaza continues
people here blame the United States for
supporting what they refer to as the
Zionist regime's indiscriminate Massacre
of the Palestinian people but this is
not the only point of view here many
Iranians have chosen not to attend
government organized
demonstrations I don't generally
participate in these rallies because I
participated once in
1979 and that was enough for
me I don't take part in the rallies
because they are governmental it is
possible Iran could get involved and for
us this would be a
disaster a disaster authorities here
want to avoid as well but the government
continues to show its full support for
the Palestinian people and resistance
groups and has launched a media campaign
to raise awareness among the Iranian
public a public that's gone through a
very difficult year since the death of
22-year-old NASA amini in police custody
in September
2022 the government organizes all these
gatherings to somehow restore the
enthusiasm that people had in the past
for example on day they wanted to erase
all those incidents the woman life
Freedom Movement and just ignore it or
to say it's all over and this is the
real face of
Iran the popularity support and
legitimacy which Iran once enjoyed no
longer
exists for now both the US and Iran are
treading carefully and what happens in
Gaza could determine the next chapter in
their tumultuous
relationship dorsa Jabari Al jazer
tan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer